Justin here with the game spot news
updates rock band 4 developer Harmonix
has admitted that some of its employees
were posting positive reviews of its
game on Amazon the admission comes after
a reddit user discovered that many of
the names match the names of employees
of harmonics in a statement to
Destructoid harmonics said it has
clarified its internal policy about
posting reviews of our own products on
retail site and we've asked that
existing reviews be edited to identify
harmonics employees or be removed
entirely harmonics went on to say that
they never intended to deceive anyone
even though the game has been getting
mostly positive reviews the developers
still labeled the actions as
inappropriate while we believe the
reviews posted by a few employees were
sincere and without ill intentions as a
studio we don't believe these are
appropriate actions it added we
appreciate the feedback from the
community and take our relationship with
our fans seriously rock band 4 came out
earlier this month for PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one our own Scott Butterworth gave
the game at seven out of 10 that's kind
of embarrassing but let's be honest why
are you going to Amazon for your reviews
you could come to gamespot and for even
more news you're already in the right
place
you